c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 est la
une ce soir le début d'une semaine
diplomatique pour le mali elle commence
par une réunion des ministres européens
des affaires étrangères ce lundi
d'autres au grand rendez vous
diplomatiques sont prévues cette semaine
'l'annonce sur un probable retrait des
soldats français et européens engagés au
mali est attendue alors que bamako
poursuit son bras de fer avec la cedeao
plus d'un an et demi loin des bancs de
l'école pendant la crise sanitaire c'est
un record mondial détenu par l'ouganda
les conséquences sur l'éducation des
élèves sont énormes la moitié d'entre
eux n'a bénéficié d'aucun enseignement
pendant cette période
reportage de notre envoyé spécial dans
ce jaune et à la fin de cette édition je
vous emmène au bénin à la découverte
d'une oeuvre d'art réalisées par un trio
d'artistes africains une oeuvre qu'il
quittera la terre pour l'espace sur la
coiffe d'ariane 5 les détails à suivre
agitation diplomatique autour du mali
cette semaine une réunion des ministres
des affaires étrangères a eu lieu ce
lundi d'autres rendez vous sont prévus
cette semaine l'annnonce du d'un retrait
des troupes françaises et européennes du
pays est attendu il s'agira également de
détail et l'évolution du dispositif
militaire dans le pays le chef de la
diplomatie française jean yves le drian
a été clair la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans le sahel se poursuivra
il est également revenu sur wagner le
groupe privé russe de mercenaires et ils
affirment leur présence au mali écoutez
donc c'est la jungle qui s'isole c'est
la gêne qui perd c'est la junte qu'ils
aient failli et qui devra assumer la
suite et pia problème militaire
qui est le fait que progressivement on a
des entraves à notre nos capacités
opérationnelles
que
on voit européens avec lesquels il y
avait des accords du mois écrit qui sont
envoyées du jour au lendemain on nous
demande de modifier le traité qui nous
unit au mali pour assurer notre propre
section de notre propre fonctionnement
militaire et puis en plus wagner qui
arrivent et maritimes et guy wagner ce
sont les mercenaires russes un millier
maintenant et qui ont vraiment pour
objectif affiché de
protéger la junte
et qui se font payer comme de bon
mercenaire c'est à dire que le mali dont
on reconnaît les difficultés financières
en plus ils payent donc dans ces
conditions là c'est difficile de
continuer dans l'état
et pendant ce temps les autorités
maliennes poursuivre leur bras de fer
avec la cedeao fort d'un appui populaire
les colonel putschiste tente de faire
lever les sanctions imposées par
l'organisation ouest africaine mais la
classe politique malienne se mobilisent
pour appeler à la désescalade verbal
pour une transition apaisée reportage
dans notre correspondante à bamako en
fleurs lespiau
yacouba et mahamadou font partie de
cette jeunesse qui a décidé d'élever la
voix pour soutenir le nouvel homme fort
du pays et président de la transition le
colonel simi
[Musique]
deux amis chante au nationalisme et
appelle le peuple malien à se rassembler
pour un mali nouveau comme beaucoup il
dénonce le modèle démocratique mise à
mal par la mauvaise gouvernance et la
corruption ces trente dernières années
cetto non les autorités maliennes parce
que dès leur apparition
quand on voit qu'ils aiment ou pas mal
de choses ont changé avec assimi guitare
le peuple a sa fierté a reconnu la
fierté maintenant
puis on est sûrs de nous l'espoir est là
les utilités on les soutient tout le
temps parce que nous on peut même sens
la cedeao mais au sein de la société
civile les avis divergent certains
n'osent plus prendre la parole
publiquement pour ibrahima sangho à la
tête d'une plateforme de plusieurs
associations civiles l'urgence est au
consensus national pour permettre la
tenue d'élections démocratiques où
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de débat entre
les autres attractions et la classe
politique et cela est dommage et les
autorités ont l'obligation de s'asseoir
avec tout le monde pour discuter de la
suite à faire nous sommes dans un
système démocratique et le système de
contraintes et grasset règle tous les
textes disent que l'armée n'a pas
vocation à exercer le pouvoir politique
le pouvoir politique a prêté au civil
tandis que les autorités de transition
semble avoir renoué le dialogue avec la
cedeao en créant un groupe de travail
l'opposition a annoncé qu'elle ne
reconnaîtrait plus les autorités au
pouvoir au delà du délai de la
transition le 25 mars amadou goïta
vice-président de ce rassemblement
déplore l'absence de mesures concrètes
et l'isolément d'un pays déjà en crise
aucune action n'a été posée pour amorcer
le retour à leur concessionnaire tout a
été fait pour nous mettre devant le fait
accompli et nous devons arrêter ces
discours populiste discours
propagandistes ses discours
ultranationaliste ça ne sert absolument
à rien
le mal et a besoin de tous ses enfants
de mal et a besoin de tous ses amis de
mener a besoin de tous ses partenaires
des partenaires comme la france l europe
qui réfléchissent à la réorganisation de
leur engagement au sahel sept soldats
sénégalais retenu à prisonnier depuis un
affrontement meurtrier le 24 janvier
dernier ont été libérés par des rebelles
de casamance soldats ont été libérés en
gambie ils sont membres de la mission
militaire ouest africaine dans ce pays
la correspondance à dakar délit même
d'un
la libération des sept soldats
sénégalais a eu lieu au cours d'une
cérémonie symbolique de remise d'otages
qui a vu la participation de
représentants de la cedeao et de deux
représentants de la croix-rouge
internationale a noté l'absence de
représentants de dakar au cours de cette
cérémonie mais également l'absence de
salif sadio le principal chef des
indépendantistes du mouvement des forces
démocratiques de la casamance les
militaires sénégalais étaient détenus
depuis le 24 janvier après des
accrochages entre un militaire
sénégalais membre de la mission ouest
africaine en gambie les comme id et des
indépendantistes du mfdc quatre
militaires sénégalais avait d'ailleurs
été tués dans ces affrontements a les
militaires sénégalais était dans une
opération de lutte contre le trafic de
bois selon l'armée sénégalaise cet
épisode à deux nouveaux attisé les
tensions entre dakar et les
indépendantistes du mfdc aux prises dans
un conflit séparatiste depuis quatre
décennies il faut quand même noter que
ce conflit est retombé dans une relative
accalmie depuis une vingtaine d'années
l'armée sénégalaise informe que les
soldats sénégalais libéré sur la zone
bon état physique en général elle assure
également continuer à protéger la
l'intégrité du territoire national a
également lutter contre le trafic
illicite et d'allemand à participer aux
différentes initiatives régionales de
maintien de la paix
ce verdict en somalie la région du
puntland
dans la région du puntland la justice a
condamné quatre hommes pour l'assassinât
de notre confrère somaliens jamal phare
à aden en mars dernier l'association des
journalistes somaliens qui s'est battu
pour que justice soit faite rappelle que
les journalistes sont régulièrement
victimes de violences et appelle au
respect de leurs droits la
correspondance anaérobie de baciro ni
les quatre accusés ont été condamnés par
la cour de justice militaire de la
région du puntland deux d'entre eux sont
condamnés à la peine capitale ils seront
exécutés les deux autres purgeront des
peines de prison de 15 et 25 ans les
deux premiers sont ceux qui ont tué le
journaliste de radio très connu au
puntland jamal phare à aden qui
réalisait des reportages critiques du
groupe terroriste al shabab les deux
autres étaient seulement des complices
le groupe terroriste al shabab à payer
50 dollars les assassins pour qu'ils
tuent ce journaliste il faut rappeler
qu'en somalie les terroristes et bien
s'attaque très régulièrement à la presse
nos confrères vivent un enfer au
quotidien il est extrêmement compliqué
pour eux de faire leur travail l'an
dernier deux d'entre eux ont été tués
jamal phare à aden dont je vous parlais
ainsi que le directeur de radio
mogadiscio qui a été tué durant une
explosion qui visait son véhicule dans
la capitale somalienne mais voilà les
journalistes ne sont pas les victimes
unique du groupe terroriste al shabab
ils sont aussi attaqués par les forces
de l'ordre somalienne c'est ce que
révèle un rapport publié la semaine
dernière par l'association des
journalistes somaliens il explique que
durant l'année 2000 21 63 faits de
violence à l'égard des journalistes or
assassinats ont été recensés nombre
d'entre eux ont été arrêtés par la
police certains ont été torturés des
femmes ont été attaqués ils demandent à
ce que leurs droits soient garantis est
ce que la liberté de la presse soit
garanti comme le dit la constitution
mais voilà pour l'heure ce n'est pas le
cas ces journalistes vivent dans des
conditions extrêmement dangereuses au
quotidien que ce soit à cause du groupe
terroriste al shabab ou encore des
forces de l'ordre
les écoliers aux gants des ont repris le
chemin de l'école le 10 janvier dernier
après 20 mois de fermeture à cause de la
crise sanitaire c'est la plus longue
fermeture dans le monde pendant cette
période de pandémie parmi les 15
millions d'élèves restez à la maison la
moitié n'a reçu aucune éducation pas
même à distance à la reprise les frais
de scolarité en double et reportage de
notre correspondant dans la région sinon
wohlfarth
à cette heure en bronze - tsinghua
devrait être en classe mais depuis le
début de la pandémie qu'ovide il doit
travailler pour aider sa famille dans le
besoin
je fabrique des briques pour que je
puisse gagner de quoi payer les frais de
scolarité
avec un peu de chance je vais pouvoir
arrêter les briques et retourner étudier
weeks and al gore
ambrose a de quoi s'inquiéter
selon le gouvernement un jeune ougandais
sur trois pourrait ne jamais reprendre
les études
et agnès sa mère n'a plus les moyens de
payer les frais de scolarité pour ses
huit enfants
et tout communiqué school je les ai
emmenés dans une école publique mais
même là-bas ils demandent des uniformes
ils demandent des frais d'admission des
livres moi je suis une mère seule je
n'ai pas de travail ni de sources de
revenus au quotidien et inka ces
établissements publics mon chien le plus
nombreux se retrouvent aujourd'hui à
sailly d'élèves
si on accueille 40 % d'enfants de plus
qu'en 2020 connais du monde qui casse la
cdppt actes nous avons besoin de plus
d'enseignants les enfants doivent être
divisées en plus petites classes 90
enfants dans une salle vraiment ce n'est
pas gérable c'est allé tous les biens
publics est beau de nombreux
professionnels de l'éducation ou hausse
le ton contre cette situation des traces
alors qu'elle a de lourdes conséquences
sur le développement du capital humain
il faut que le gouvernement agisse et
prennent des mesures pour que les
enfants n'ont pas émis 10 pendant deux
ans pour rattraper leur retard au stade
est fondatrice
d'après l'onu dans les pays en
développement soient sont 10% des
enfants de 10 ans serait désormais
capable de lire contre 53% 2020 la part
des murs est anéantie 20 ans de progrès
dans l'éducation dans le monde
les efforts des états unis dans la lutte
anti copie de 19 sur le continent notre
correspondante à washington sonia dridi
s'est entretenu avec le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken elle
l'a interrogé sur les 3 millions de
dollars que les états unis ont investi à
l'institut pasteur de dakar pour la
fabrication du vaccin au sénégal écoutez
sa réponse
malheureusement on sait qu' il y aura un
autre pandémique il faut qu'on soit
mieux préparée et plus efficace mais
pour le moment on est convaincu qu'avec
une coordination approfondie sur pour
combler les vides qui existent on peut
mettre fin comme ils disent ne très
impressionnés justement de cette visite
au sénégal et à l'institut pasteur ça
souligne non seulement le besoin mais la
capacité qui existent de produire à
l'échelle nationale régionale à travers
le monde ça rendra la tâche beaucoup
plus efficace à l'avenir et surtout ne
pas dépendre des chaînes
d'approvisionnement qui qui sont
globales et les réduire pour s'assurer
que dans un moment de crise on peut
avoir un impact immédiat
voilà pour cet extrait de l'entretien
exclusif que le secrétaire d'état
américain accordée à nos correspondants
à washington vous pouvez le retrouver
dans son intégralité sur nous n et sur
notre site internet allez pour finir je
vous emmène au bénin figurez vous que
dans quelques mois pour la toute
première fois dans l'histoire une oeuvre
d'art réalisées par des artistes
africains contemporains quittera la
terre pour aller dans l'espace le
lanceur européen ariane 5 embarquera
aussi avec lui un satellite crucial pour
l'afrique nos correspondantes emmanuel
sodji et nathalie verdier ont rencontré
au bénin les artistes
dans le monde de l'art contemporain le
congolais de kinshasa michel et kéba est
connu pour ses performances afro
futuriste
ils fabriquent et enfilent des
combinaison de cosmonaute à partir des
déchets russie
sa compatriote j'ai râlé daube et autres
figures emblématiques de l'actuelle
scène artistique congolaise elle nous
fait pénétrer dans son monde parallèle
peuplé de silhouettes peintes avec le
feu
[Musique]
le camerounais jean david m troc lui
c'est le peintre de la condition humaine
ses oeuvres sont des visages submergé
par deux motifs qui interroge des
consciences
il faut prendre du recul pour voir si
tous les éléments sont bien équilibrées
c'est fantastique
quand vous avez des idées et que vous
créez quelque chose de si profond et
aussi futuriste est à la fois ces six
actuelles
switcher en
résidence artistique au bénin à ouidah
les trois jeunes artistes ont dû faire à
dialoguer ensemble des univers et des
techniques totalement opposés tous les
trois on devrait mettre la main sur une
surface et de n'est pas fair troisième
différents mais qu'est que c'est toi
c'est 3 démarche artistique puisse faire
qu'un scène donc ça c'est ce n'était pas
facile la question du réchauffement
climatique dont souffre le plus de
continent africain est au centre de ce
projet artistique
on a fait le constat que la météorologie
d'observation météorologique est un
élément vraiment crucial pour imaginer
le futur de l'afrique est née l'idée que
le premier objet qui pourrait partir en
même temps qu'un nouveau satellite
d'observation météorologique pour
l'afrique soit une oeuvre d'art
l'oeuvre unique des trois artistes qui
sera envoyée dans l'espace sur la
croisette ariane 5 reflète le rêve d'une
afrique et d'une planète où toutes les
populations pourraient vivre dans un
environnement propre et durable dans le
futur
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audry racines
[Musique]